Donald Trump has been insisting for awhile
that he does not know love. Parness Parness
is the now indicted henchman of Rudy Giuliani
who was working on Donald Trump's behalf in
Europe and in the Ukraine fiasco. Love. Parness
was one of the people involved along with
Igor Fruman in putting Ukrainian, uh, ambassador
to Ukraine, Maria Bonovitch under physical
surveillance, which is a bonkers thing for
someone indirectly hired by or hired by the
president's personal attorney to be doing.
And we recently had one video released where
Lev Parness was at a dinner with Donald Trump
and they were talking about taking out ambassador
Marie Ivana bitch. And now a second video
has been released. This second video is 37
minutes long. It's a private gathering of
Republican donors, which took place at Donald
Trump's Mar-a-Lago resort. Apparently on April
20th, 2018 Lordy, there are even more tapes
as James Komie would say. Parness himself
is videotaped at one point posing with Donald
Trump. Now, the interesting thing about the
timing is if I understand the timing correctly,
this second video would actually have been
from an event 10 days before the video that
was released last week or the week before.
So this means that when Donald Trump and Parness
were speaking about Maria Bonovitch at the
dinner in video number one, they had just
10 days prior, been at this other event together
at Mar-a-Lago to get a, and of course, remember
Donald Trump insists he doesn't know the guy.
The second video appears to have been filmed
by Igor Fruman. He's the other indicted henchman
of Rudy Giuliani. And in the video, Parness
and Trump don't have much of a conversation.
As we know in the first video they talk about
Maria Vantiv, it's Ukraine and other issues.
Um, in this video, they don't seem to do that.
Now I wish I could tell you that this is all
going to make any kind of difference, but
I think most people who watched this program
with any regularity, no, none of this stuff
is going to make any difference. We heard
from Trump lawyer Alan Dershowitz that as
long as there's some plausible or even not
that plausible, quite frankly, public interests
that can be claimed for an action that Donald
Trump takes. The action is essentially fine.
This was the crux of Alan Dershowitz. His
argument as an attorney representing Donald
Trump in the Senate impeachment trial.
We are coming up on, or by the time you watch
this, it may have already happened, the impending
acquittal of Donald Trump by Republican senators
in a complete joke of an impeachment trial
in the Senate. They lie all the time about
not knowing Parness. It's an obvious lie.
Parness has the receipts. It doesn't matter.
They no longer even pretend that what Donald
Trump is doing isn't questionable. They are
now of the mindset that if Trump does it effectively,
it's okay. Impeachment holding the president
accountable, all of that, that would be trying
to undo an election whose results you didn't
like. You don't even need to hear from firsthand
witnesses to Trump's wrongdoing. Even when
you claimed for months. You want firsthand
witnesses. We are not, uh, in a situation
where there are going to be consequences for
any of this. We are living in a very disturbing
nightmare that may not end for five more years.
Even the appearance of misbehavior by Donald
Trump can't be investigated by some. Remember
the first position was, well, you can indict
a sitting president. They moved on to, we
don't even think you can investigate a sitting
president. Imagine that increasingly the tone
and tenor of the defenses are more and more
reminiscent of Richard Nixon's. If the president
does it, it's not illegal, and that should
strike fear into every single one of us. But
for Trump's base, it seems to fire them up.
It seems to actually excite and titillate
them into agreeing and unquestioningly repeating.
If the president can even cite some completely
flacid and unbelievable justification in the
public interest of what he does, then by debt,
by its very nature, it's not certainly not
illegal. Certainly not impeachable. There's
not even be a consequence or an investigation.
So as far as the videos from Lev Parness,
we'll see if more videos are released through
left Parness his attorney.
In the end, I don't think it's going to do
much unless they may be inspire people not
to vote for Trump in 2020 at this point. I
think even if you know the so-called P P tapes
are real. If you have a video of Trump shooting
someone, but like all this cartoonish stuff,
I still don't think that the vast majority
of Trump's base reconsiders whether to support
him in 2020 if any of that stuff even hypothetically
existed. Hopefully all of this will do one
thing which is inspire people on our side
to get out and vote in November of 2020 that
is the one shot we have of removing the mango
menace, the Tangerine terror. I really hope
that left Parness and now I'm sort of kidding
here, but I'm sort of serious. If Lev Parness
accidentally falls on a knife six times and
accidentally throws himself off of a balcony,
I hear those knives can jump right out at
you. That would be a terrible thing. I hope
that doesn't happen if people understand what
it is that I'm saying. I hope I'm kidding.
I'm probably 80% kidding. Let's take a quick
break. I want to show you some amazing video
of Mike Pence confront, confronted by an emergency
room doctor. We are also going to talk about
the latest GDP numbers from 2019 which we
now have that are interesting.
I have voicemail. We have the bonus show.
There is still much more to come. Today is
the primary message that I'm trying to transmit
to you here